a lot of fun characters on Kroll show
anything new that we can look forward to
anything you're working on developing
well I was gonna do child paparazzo but
I think that's a mistake now your
timings off
yeah just make the paparazzo a child
work but I do have a new character that
I would love to make the world premiere
of tonight here on your show a show yeah
[Applause]
the it's very exciting it's the
character I call 70s eater
70s eater yeah it's a guy who eats like
he's in a 70s movie a guy who eats like
he's in a 70s V so I unfortunately I
need food to do this bit that's okay I
always keep a lot of food right here oh
great yeah perfect yeah arbol load yeah
so yeah so the idea is so if I know
would you be willing to can you help me
out sure let's just pretend like we're
in a you know it's like a Scorsese movie
or something like that 1973 yeah exactly
we're at a diner we're old friends we
haven't seen each other you work for me
and you know yeah there you go
okay I'm gonna loosen the tie a little
bit I work for you yeah okay all right
you know we're you have a meeting that
you're being called to that you might
not be exactly ready for okay and your
70s eater guy all right and you tell me
when to go you're in charge gotta get
that ready good okay here we go and you
have your moment before okay right yep
here we go
oh nothing at all I'm talking at all
yeah everything's going good boss
everything's good Nick clearly the real
good Nick yeah a car I saw your mom got
a little car yeah she got a new car come
on my mom's got a new car I just got her
the new Cadillac I got my mom the new
catalog very nice Eldorado
yeah very fancy for a guy like you well
you know I save my money yeah sweetheart
let me get a cup of coffee please
cup of coffee okay there we go yeah all
right so anyway yeah I say hmm nice this
coffee's nice cuz it's not that hot yeah
okay so anyway my mom oh my god of the
car and you know I work hard I put aside
the money and I gotta remain Coweta
Rosalie Kohler I mean Katya where were
you getting the money for something like
that Klein put it aside
that's it carefully put the money aside
yeah Toma JPMorgan here you you know
Andrew Andrew wait about yeah Oh Andrew
yeah he's the kind of guy that he takes
care of people for you yeah takes care
what uh what ironic that he's here
running sweetheart let me get a steak
grey thin hard to cut with with pieces
of fat on the side place
so anyway yeah I wouldn't do that why
I'm the boss
[Laughter]